welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am of course not David Pakman I am
Benjamin Dixon host of the Benjamin
Dixon show you can find my podcast
everywhere so be sure to check it out
David will be back tomorrow let's talk
about the President of the United States
and I don't I don't want to say it's
it's an unwitting occurrence I think he
knows what he's doing
but he has a way of ensuring that his
audience has an has absolutely no grip
on reality whatsoever and he can do it
all in one sentence and no one pays any
attention to it what the hell am I
talking about I'm talking about the
President of the United States in a
single sentence he says polls are fake
and then just maybe two seconds later he
uses a poll to justify why he's the most
popular Republican president in history
don't take my word for it listen to the
president yourself Paul they're called
suppression Paul's you know polls are
faked just like everything else if the
fake news to the poll it would show that
I'm only getting 25% with the 401 K
people even though they're up 44% now we
got we're doing well we're doing well
and I'm happy you're doing well they
just came out with a Paul did you hear
the most popular person in the history
of the Republican Party is Trump can you
believe
I don't know what to do with this they
are literally cheering the fact that the
President of the United States just told
them the poles are fake right so if the
poles are fake doesn't it just make
sense doesn't it logically follow that
the pole that he's now saying is a good
pole is also fake but what the president
has an uncanny knack of doing is saying
anything that I disagree with anything
that's not flattering anything that
doesn't support me is fake but if it
supports me it's real and this is the
premise that has spread through the
Republican Party like this is people
want to consider leftists and
progressives and Democrats as having the
trump derangement syndrome but I think
that there's really a true Trump
derangement syndrome and that is from
people who who reject any information
that is non flattering any unflattering
any information that they disagree with
with regard to Trump and accepting that
same information from the same source if
they like the what is saying and this is
what the president does he encourages
this and the people following and I want
to play a clip from last week everybody
remembers this clip from last week when
he basically told them don't believe
your eyes don't believe your ears tickle
isn't in but it's all working out and
just remember what you're seeing and
what you're reading is not what's
happening it this is this is directly
from 1984 right the the most essential
rule the most essential command from the
from Big Brother was that you reject
what your eyes and ears were seeing
this doesn't bother conservatives this
doesn't even this doesn't make them
uncomfortable like here's a difference
people want to draw equivalences between
Democrats and Republicans conservatives
and progressives all the time but the
reality of it is is that on the Left we
will call you out for your BS we don't
care who you are we don't care if you
are President Barack Obama or if you're
President Donald Trump if you come to us
with something that is obscenely
logically inconsistent so much so that
you you contradict yourself in a single
sentence we're gonna call you out on it
without question but Republicans they
like sheep to the slaughter they line up
and they eat this stuff up they eat it
up they got
because it just it confirms their biases
yes but more than anything else it just
over inflates their sense of success in
this Trump administration they have to
always win Donald Trump promised them
that they're gonna be winning so much so
the only way that they can continue to
win is if they reject anything that says
that they're not winning let's forget
about the fact that North Korea is still
expanding their their weapons in their
arsenal their nuclear arsenal because
Donald Trump said that that North Korea
was getting rid of them so reject the
evidence let's accept what Donald Trump
says forget the fact that the economy
actually performed better underneath
President Obama in several quarters
Donald Trump said that the economy is
performing better than it's ever
performed in the history of ever
performing so they accept that and
that's the only way that they could
actually go through this era of Trump
and and not have their brains explode
from the logical inconsistencies from
the cognitive dissonance that occurs
simply by supporting someone like Donald
Trump and the fact that matter is you're
not going to always win
I don't even believe I have to say this
like I'm ashamed that I even have to say
this Donald Trump is not going to be
perfect in fact in so many ways
he's already screwed up but if you're
going to look for your leader to always
be triumphant no matter what then you're
gonna find yourself in a position that
conservatives are currently in where
they consistently reject reality in
order to promote this idea that they are
always winning
congratulations Republicans you played
yourself I'm pleased to tell you that
today's show is underwritten by better
help.com slash Pakman therapy is
important we have a real crisis in our
country not just people who could
benefit from mental health services but
the stigma that surrounds mental health
services and as many people in the
audience know lots of people in my
family work in the field of mental
health and I have made it a mission of
the show to at any opportunity make
clear that there is absolutely no shame
whatsoever in going to talk to someone
when you feel that that's the right
thing to do and that's what better help
provides you get a fully licensed and
experienced psychologists and therapists
through video phone and text it's less
expensive than meeting in person with a
counselor after three months the price
goes down even more but you get the same
professional service that you would from
going into somebody's office and you
also get unlimited access you can speak
to a counselor every day if you want
signing up is easy you go to better help
calm slash Pakman fill out a
questionnaire they will pair you with a
therapist that works for you but you're
always able to switch to somebody else
if there's a better fit available go to
better help calm slash Pakman it's so
easy to sign up and get started we're
putting a link in the description if
you're watching this on YouTube it is
better help calm a slash PA que ma n